Ahh, I am happy! I like making videos for
you guys... you guys are the best! But I have
got to call this trend out. Less > less > more.
Here's my version of that fad: less > less
> and now more! But whoa whoa whoa, this isn't
going to be video chaos! Let me orient you.
First, these beauties - animated takes on
language and communication. These take like
20-plus hours per minute of finished footage,
so please enjoy. No pressure. But enjoy them.
In Eavesdropping Traveler, each vignette takes
a charming, quirky look at a destination through
its local language. I take pictures, create
art and even write music for these.
Finally, what began as plans for a behind-the-scenes
take is turning into its own series. A series
that's more direct, a bit vloggy and ties
in a random topic each time.
Oh, wait! There's still the old stuff.
Last year's questions about human language
and the even older technical lessons aren't
getting updated, but they're still around.
See you in the videos!